Has anyone ever been to Aspen, Colorado?
It's not a joke yet;
those aren't the jokes.
Is this thing off?
I went to Aspen recently
and stumbled into this song.
♫ Black men go to Aspen ♫
♫ and rent colorful chalets. ♫
♫ Giggle at the questions ♫
♫ their mere presence seems to raise. ♫
♫ Get taken for men ♫
♫ we don't resemble in the least. ♫
"Are you ... ?"
"No."
♫ It's a winter wonderland ♫
♫ in the belly of the beast. ♫
♫ And black men ski. ♫
♫ Black men ski. ♫
♫ Black men send back sushi ♫
♫ with a scorned Yakuza's flair. ♫
♫ We make postmodern art ♫
♫ with bacon grease ♫
♫ and hot combed hair. ♫
♫ We secretly play Beethoven ♫
♫ inside our bassmobiles. ♫
♫ We can tell you how cool looks ♫
♫ but cannot show you how it feels ♫
♫ when black men ski. ♫
♫ When black men ski. ♫
♫ Black men now are students ♫
♫ of gay sensibility. ♫
♫ We wear ironic T-shirts ♫
♫ drenched in code unknown to thee. ♫
♫ We get baptized in Walden Pond ♫
♫ amongst a searing mob ♫
♫ because the cleansing blood of Jesus ♫
♫ could not do a thorough job. ♫
♫ Black men ski. ♫
♫ Chinese guys can jump real high ♫
♫ and Germans cook soul food. ♫
♫ White boys rap and hippies nap ♫
♫ their dreads up to look rude. ♫
♫ Jazz is now suburban ♫
♫ it's Marsalisly clean. ♫
♫ And now we've got Viagra ♫
♫ everyone's a sex machine. ♫
♫ So black men ski. ♫
What else can we do?
♫ Black men ski. ♫
♫ Some kids I'll describe as friends ♫
♫ say I am race-obsessed. ♫
♫ The luxury of your opinion ♫
♫ shows that you are blessed. ♫
♫ See, I have poems about sunsets ♫
♫ flowers and the rain. ♫
♫ I've read them to policemen ♫
♫ but it was all in vain. ♫
♫ So black men ski. ♫
♫ Black men ski ... ♫
elegantly.
♫ Black men ski. ♫